experts don't know [ __ ] and by the way
before you get offended and say pat i
don't like what you have to say about
this listen if i don't make sense don't
like the video comment negatively
underneath but if i do make some give it
a thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
so watch this just a couple years ago
i made a video and i said look i think
gas price is going to go to 10 bucks oh
my god you're just using these fear
tactics this is not the truth you don't
know what you're talking about experts
with the fancy degrees said gas price is
never going to go to numbers like that
we have it under control uh it just hit
all time record high in the history of
us
today
news was just released gas is an
all-time high in u.s we've never had
this before but it's not going to go
higher really what do you think you
think experts are riding that with gas
prices not going any higher and then
they said inflation yeah it's not going
to go that high you know maybe it's
going to get to six percent but that's
it because we got it under control my
name is janet yellen i know what i'm
talking about my name is i'm the expert
i got the fancy degree inflation just
hit 8.3 and by the way folks it ain't
gonna slow down people think this is it
don't be fooled it's still going up then
people said oh but interest rates he's
just gonna raise it once or twice or
three times but it's not gonna get that
ugly it's not gonna get that ugly six
months ago interest rates by three
percent everybody was refinancing oh
three percent refinancing it's great
it's 5.3 percent today and by the way
just in 2000 which is 22 years ago do
you know what interest rates were in
america
8.3
oh it'll never go to 8.3 why not why
will not go to 8.3 tell me the last time
we printed as much money as we have
printed where
value of dollar goes down but we have to
figure out a way what we're going to do
with all this fake money that we got out
there given to everybody yes guess what
inflation is going to go up interests
are going to go up gas prices are going
to go up and don't think it's only at
5.3 percent do not be surprised if
interest rates crack 8 to 12
within the next 12 to 24 months with the
direction that we're going by the way
they asked
the press secretary expert hey what are
we going to do with all these parents
who have infants there's no baby formula
everywhere you're going there is no baby
formula we just had a kid what do we
tell these parents
i recommend them to go talk to their
doctor
the the doctor cannot prescribe food
the doctor cannot prescribe baby formula
yeah but let them go talk to you're the
expert yeah yeah but you got to go talk
to
the doctor because the doctor was the
last we went to the doctor and doctor
prescribed your kid food when's the last
time we did that here's the point listen
you know who the expert is let me
explain to the expert is today elizabeth
warren oh my god she's losing her mind
oh my god when are we going to cancel
the student that i can't believe what's
going on with roe v i can't believe all
this stuff right
okay the experts want us to cancel debt
hey experts why don't you tell us
why
since 1980 the cpi consumer price index
inflation is up around 220 percent while
colleges and universities are up 1180
plus percent explain to me
how they have a thousand percent more
than inflation has college education
improved by a thousand percent i'm sorry
just 20 something years ago the average
salary or in 1980 the average salary you
and i were getting was 20 some thousand
dollars today's 40 some thousand dollars
so if my salary has barely doubled maybe
it's doubled by 100 some percent but you
know college education has gone up 1200
percent has education improved by that
much come on experts elizabeth warren
why don't you tell us since you're the
smart one you go to school you're a
professor and you got a degree and us
the amateurs who are not the experts who
are paying the price we have kids we're
sending our kids to school and all this
cost is 30 40 50 60 74 000 at harvard
while during covet harvard said no even
though you're doing it through zoom
we're going to keep the tuition the same
price because when you can brag about a
harvard degree while they're sitting on
enough endowment that they don't need to
take a single tuition for a student for
the next hundred years and they can
afford it oh but let's cancel the
student oh yeah yeah experts great job
right there no how about before we
cancel the student debt
how about we first go renegotiate for
colleges to lower
cost of tuition come on experts you're
the expert i'm just an amateur talking
here on a youtube channel i'm a regular
guy i want to hear from you experts
here's a point stop letting these
so-called experts confuse you
how do you feel when you go pay the
price on gas prices do you think twice
about visiting grandma or somebody else
that you're driving two hours away
because it's gonna cost you twice as
much as before you're the expert
you're feeling the pain okay hey parent
of an infant if you're feeling the pain
and they're claiming they're the experts
maybe you know how about you who bought
a house
and you just bought the house six months
ago and you paid eight hundred thousand
dollars for that house in the next 12 to
24 months that house is gonna probably
be worth 550 000
you're feeling the pride you're feeling
the pain you're going through it you're
the expert moral the story
the next two years are going to be very
ugly i'm telling you right now and by
the way i've been kind of saying that
this time is coming for a long time and
everybody was like pat's just trying to
get views
pat's just trying to get views with
market crash when he talks market crash
i've done two market crash videos okay
one of them was how to prepare when it
comes and it's coming
whether you were prepared for it or not
it's coming i hope you've been prepared
for because if you are these are good
times for those who are prepared for it
but all these things we talked about
they're all probably going to be
happening rates are going to continue to
go up gas prices are going to continue
to go up inflation is going to continue
to go up and these jobs that some people
that were going job hopping hey go ask
your boss if they don't give you twenty
thousand dollar rates go to another
company do it believe me the strategy
works tell them you got a job offer for
my headhunter hey i'd like to talk to
you what's that i know you guys pay me
65 000 i just got an offer for 85 plus a
10 000 bonus but if you match it i'll
stay here oh my gosh oh my god what do
we do what do we do i guess we have to
match it that's the market right now
okay let's match it yeah awesome thank
you so much for matching it go to the
other box and say hey
they match it and they give me a bonus
what if we give you a hundred five
thousand dollars with a fifteen thousand
dollar bonus
i'll take it so they used you to get
that job and then they go to that
company
and then they realize
that the market value for their true
skills is not 110 it's really 65 to 70.
and today carvana just announced they're
firing
10 of their workforce i don't know how
many four thousand they're firing a lot
of people
you're going to see that in silicon
valley all the major companies say
there's a freeze we're not hiring
anymore you're about to hear banks
letting go of 10 20 30 of their
employees you're going to hear companies
make these announcements and the
market's going to say um you're not
worth 105. people were just scared of
losing you and you bullied them and you
got what you wanted but guess what now
your resume is going to say you've had
three jobs in the last 12 months
you're kind of like a 65 000 audio
person go get that job and become the
best you can and then increase your
market value and eventually someone's
going to pay you 110. but people are not
naive here's a moral of the story
everybody on msnbc was saying if
somebody gives you the money go get it
go get it take the job oh really even
though these guys have been good for me
for seven years going yes
okay because msm experts don't know [ __ ]
they've confused america and the world
the last two years
i want you to even question what i'm
saying sit there and say pat how about
you you don't know what you're talking
about fine
go dispute everything i'm saying to you
but do your own damn due diligence and
figure out what's really taking place
and don't let everybody out there that's
screaming off the top of their lungs
just because they got a fancy degree
convince you don't worry everything's
gonna be all right not the next two
years
probably not the next two to three years
be prepared so in the military they say
stay alert stay alive
here's what motto i've used since i got
out of the military stay alert stay
paranoid stay a little suspicious
but at the same time play offense keep
getting better
do your part build good relationships
show the fact that you're reliable and
dependable keep getting better in your
area of expertise as a hard skill like
you know how to do a real hard skill get
better at that and the market's going to
favor you i guarantee you that it always
has anyways
if you're listening
and maybe you're a little bit upset but
you're saying this kind of does make
sense give it a thumbs up and subscribe
if not go watch a cat video man there's
a lot of them out there or maybe go
watch an msnbc video but if not i have
another video i want you to watch on how
to prepare for market crash if you
haven't watched it click here love you
have a wonderful day take care
[Music]